Phenotyping algorithm is very important in
supporting genome-wide association study.
What is a genome-wide association study? It's an
approach that involves scanning biomarkers such
as single nucleotide polymorphism,
or SNPs, from DNA of many people,
in order to find genetic variation, associated
with a particular disease field phenotypes.
Once new genetic associations are
identified, researchers can use that
information to develop better strategies.
To detect and treat and prevent diseases.
So, how are genomic
wide-association studies conducted?
To run a genomic wide-association study, or
GWAS, we first identify the disease phenotypes.
Then group the participants into these
two groups, cases and these are people
with disease phenotypes. And controls, those are
similar patient without the disease phenotype.
Then we need to obtain DNA samples from
all these participants. From DNA samples,
we can use lab machines to quickly survey each
participant's genomes for genetic variation.
Which are called single-nucleotide polymorphism
or SNP. If certain genetic variation have found
to be significantly more frequent in the people
with the disease phenotypes compared to people
without the disease phenotype. These variations
are said to be associated with the disease.
We do this by computing the frequencies of SNPs
on the cases and on the controls. Then based on
the frequency, we calculate the odds ratio. From
there, we can calculate the corresponding p-value
for the odds ratio. If the p-value is small,
then we conclude this variation is significant.
The associated genetic variations
can serve as powerful pointers to
the region of the human genome
that may cause the disease.
Here's an example showing more details on how
the GWAS is computed. We first identified the
cases and controls. That is, the people with
the disease phenotype and the people without
the disease phenotype. In this case, we have
4000 patients with the disease phenotype and
6000 patients without the disease phenotype.
Then we iterate over all the SNPs to compare the
relevant frequencies. For instance, for SNP1 for
the control group, we have 2676 out of 6000 has
the corresponding variation G, at this location.
And the frequency of G in this case is 44.6%.
In the case group, we have 2104 out of 4000 with
the corresponding variation G at this location.
So, the frequency is 52.6%. If we go through
the calculation, we'll find now the P-value
is 5 times 10 to the minus 15. Which means,
this is extremely significant. We can conduct
the same calculation on SNP2 and find out the
P-value here is 0.33 which is not significant.
To support GWAS study, we need to know high
quality phenotypes on the cases and controls
in order to perform this calculation, that's
why phenotyping algorithm, is very important.
As we have shown in the
genome-wide association studies,
we need phenotypic data in order to analyze
genomic data. But in general, why do we care
about phenotyping algorithms in genomic study? In
fact, many people argue that we need rich and deep
phenotypic data in order to analyze genomic data.
Especially as sequencing technology improves,
the cost of generating genomic data is
dropping so fast over time. While the
cost of computing or Moore's Law cannot keep up
with the improvement of sequencing technology,
which means we'll have more and more genomic data
in near future about many individuals. However,
due to the complexity of the electronic health
record, the cost for generating high quality
phenotypic data is actually increasing, while
the cost of genomic data is dropping drastically.
That is why we really need to invent better
phenotyping algorithms to reduce the cost
of acquiring high quality phenotypic
data and to support genomic studies.